ادله جديده تكشف علاقه روسيا بالمؤامره
الانقلابيه التي كانت تستهدف الايطاحه
بالحكومه والنظام الالماني
فالمتهم بتنظيم هذه المؤامره التقى مع
دبلوماسيين روس في قنصليه بالمانيا مره
واحده على الاقل
تفاصيل مثيره كشف عنها شخصان مطلعان على
التحقيق بشكل مباشر لصحيفه نيويورك
الفاشل زار مرتين القنصليه الروسيه وحده
هذه الزياره كانت في يونيو وتحديدا في
اليوم الذي يصادف العيد الوطني الروسي كما
تمت مصادرته حوالي 40 سلاحا ناريا في ظل
هذه مداهمه التي استهدفت الشبكه
وذلك من خلال 150 موقع مختلفا في جميع
انحاء البلاد
فضلا عن وجود مخزونات الذخيره الاخرى التي
لم يحدد موقعها بعد
وهو الامر الذي جعل السلطات الالمانيه
تبحث عن مخابئ هذه الاسلحه سلسله
المداهمات اسفرت ايضا عن توقيع اكثر من
100 اتفاقيه عدم ابشاء المعلومات والتي
اقسم الموقعون من خلالها على السريه
التامه بشان خطط الجماعه الذين يدعون
انفسهم بمواطن الرايه فمن بين الاسئله
المفتوحه ليس فقط مخابئ الاسلحه ولكن هناك
ايضا الاثار المترتبه على العديد من
القوائم التي تم العثور عليها باسماء
الاشخاص فيها
اعضاء هذه المجموعه الذين يدعمون هنرش في
انقلابه نشيطون في الجيش والشرطه
وتلقى عدد منهم تدريبات على هذه الاسلحه
وفقا للصحيفه الامريكيه اما فيما يتعلق
بخطه هذه الشبكه الانقلابيه فتضمنت اقتحام
البرلمان الالماني
وصولا الى اعتقال اعضائه كما ان المستشار
الالماني يعد الابرز على قائمه الاغتيالات
كما ضبط المحققون صوره تم التقاطها
بالهواتف المحموله لاحد المتهمين بالتامر
والتي توفق الحواجز المختلفه في احدى
المباني التي تضم مكاتب اعضاء البرلمان
وزاره العدل كشفت بدورها عن قائدين
مفترضين لهذه المجموعه الانقلابيه الاول
الامير هاريش الذي يعتقد انه العقل المدبر
للانقلاب الفاشل
اما الثاني فهو مقدم سابق في الجيش
الالماني ترك عمله في نهايه التسعينات بعد
ما خرق قانون الاسلحه ولا تزال التفاصيل
غامضه في ما يتعلق ببقيه اعضاء المجموعه
القت القبض على 23 مشتبها وتحقق مع واحد
31 شخصا اخرين حتى الان سلطان العربيه